okay excellent so um thank you all for
joining today again this webinar is on
job seeking during Coppa 19 and how to
continue career growth during turbulent
times
we're definitely in unprecedented times
you know and for all of us globally we
are in a situation where we haven't
faced before you know so we're all
learning a new way of being and so I
thought it would be helpful to have this
webinar you know in one part yes I plan
to share strategies that would be very
helpful to you that a solid search
strategies better then on the other hand
also knowing that I'm no expert there's
no one who knows how to navigate this
will probably be much better at
navigating it once it's behind us and
you know kind of lessons learned but you
know really like to keep it open would
like this session to be as interactive
as possible where you're sharing new
questions you're sharing your concerns
and then that kind of moves the
direction I have I have you know several
suggestions that I'll have for you that
will keep you engaged that will keep you
you know during you know on track for
your job search but I'm also very happy
to hear you know where you need to or
where you're struggling where you'd like
the direction of this conversation to go
so it would really be helpful for us
that okay so just a little bit a little
bit about me so I'm a passionate career
coach whose work is centered around
getting my clients to determine what
they're most passionate about defining
or redefining their lives and creating a
fulfilling and purpose driven career and
going after those seemingly impossible
dreams so just to add a little bit more
most of my background was in a charlyk
Whitman I had a career for about 15
years
up to director-level and reached all the
goals that I wanted to reach
professionally educationally but I still
found that you know I was doing work to
do work there was no passion or there
was no engagement and what I was doing
the High Line so that query that that
pushed me into a pivot in my career and
that's actually what brought me into
career coaching which is something I've
you know really been passionate about
for a long time and now my passion is to
and my life's work now is a lot you know
to help people see what their passions
is and moving to them okay so for
today's agenda like forced to kind of
just talk about the current state of
affairs you know how things are today I
mean kind of putting things into
perspective and we you know I feel like
we are so much fun barded by what is
going on in the world you know they need
the 24-hour news cycles you know that it
just student glued to my father's a day
that's just being thrown at us so we
don't get a lot of opportunity to
meaning to sit back and see the positive
of everything that's going on and so
that's one of really the goals is you
know putting things into perspective you
know realizing that you know we there is
pasta you know it can be positive that
can come out of this situation we're in
and then obviously looking at how we
need to adjust our strategy again
we are dealing with a whole new paradigm
you know we have no idea where things
will end right we don't know what things
will look like three months six months
nine months one year from now the global
market and the job market so again it's
just seeing how we can adjust our
strategy in order to accommodate for
what we best can okay and then obviously
looking at some of the companies and
secretaries that are hiring there's
always opportunity in every you know
whatever whatever is going on there's
all
opportunity so they're definitely on
some areas that are definitely hiring
and also seeing how you can be of
service how you can contribute to the
solution and then we'll end with a
question and answer session for any
questions that we haven't answered
through through the webinar so I'd like
to hear from some of you and you can
unmute yourself because I'm having a
little bit of trouble with my chatbox
today so you could please unmute
yourself and just let us know how have
you been impacted by Kovach 19 have you
been greatly impacted where it's kind of
turned their life upside down were you
kind of in between where yes you've had
to make some changes but you know really
you know nothing that you can't handle
and then four I'm sure very few of us in
life you know continues that's usual you
schedule is the same you're kind of
going in and out as you were so I'd love
to hear from you as to how things have
changed it's kind of life as usual I
mean I'm working remotely now nobody's
going into the office okay not really
going anywhere not many plans or
anything so it's impacted but I'm you
know one of the fortunate ones that I
still have a storm a job like them you
know all things considered not doing too
bad just not doing many things not too
many plans so uh-huh usual but it's just
a new type of usual okay okay well
that's good to hear
and how are you kind of keeping positive
and sane uh obviously just keeping
myself busy I'm working on the
nanodegree as best I can keep them busy
with work and trying to not pay
attention to all the news that's out
there you know in relatively uniform but
there's only so much I can take of I
don't know kind of reiterating the same
like it's spreading and all this and
that and can only take in so much so
what I have control over rather than not
you know everything that I can't really
impact much that's a great way to go
about it okay great so thank you for
sharing would anyone else like to share
okay so let's move on to the next slide
so just kind of again coming back to the
current state of affairs so obviously
all this was started by health crises
with the you know very very fast spread
the virus around the world that kind of
put this all in shutdown and then
obviously that you know affected well
it's not so much of a financial crisis
but it did affect you know a lot of
financial markets in a big way a lot of
homes and a lot of households and a lot
of countries have been affected in a
very real way financially so it would be
a financial crisis for many and
obviously on the subject of our topic
today there has been a huge slump in the
job market one because of a lot of
positions have gone away or kind of on
hold for example in sectors that have
been you know affected more greatly and
I would say that would be what the
leisure sectors restaurants the
hospitality so those have been the most
severely affected I would say bye-bye
but this situation we're in and they've
had to kind of make the biggest
adjustments right so and then while
everyone else might not have been
affected a lot don't know how this is
going to go and the operations have had
to change drastically so just from the
fact of some jobs are not able to be
done from home you know or you know some
companies don't really have the
capability of onboarding people once you
know when you're remote you know they
need to be able to be in a physical
facility to do that so so not only have
some jobs completely
I'm still the others are you know the
logistics around you know people not
being able to travel people not being
able to to you know go and report
somewhere that holding back a lot of
positions and then there's also
economics right a lot of companies I'm
not sure how this will affect them so
they're taking the conservative approach
and kind of waiting it out to see hey
you know that's kind of put out hiring
on hold and see where this goes before
you know we you know we continue and
then we end up having two to three
strategies and you know have layoffs and
all that down the line so so that's kind
of where we are with our current state
of affairs so I love this quote on
adversity so I always believe that it's
not what happens to you but how you
react to it so it's your reaction
perversity not get versity toughie
determines how your life stories will
develop we have been in this situation
time and time in history through world
wars to the Great Depression and through
you know 9/11 we you know financial
market crashes you know we've been here
before we you know had to really really
pull up our socks and really show our
resilience and short for each other and
show our families but at the end of the
day there was oh you know those always
let again paternal the situation always
came to an end in time and so
remembering that there's not much we can
do about what is happening but there is
a lot that we can do and how how okay so
perspective again kind of going back to
what I was talking about it's not you
know we can go into doom and gloom like
for example a lot of the new cycles and
some of them you know more positive than
others some really really go down the
negative spectrum and some you know try
to be a little bit positive but again
the nature of news is sharing the values
so what can you do to kind of shift your
perspective you know so you can focus on
the positive what if some of the
positive that has come out for some of
you out of this situation I'd love to
hear from you us too
you know how has what are things now
that you can say wow you know this is
something that I was never able to do
that you know now this opportunity is
allowing you to do you know what are for
you some some positive that you can get
out of the situation that you can think
back on your life and your family or
your career and say wow this is
something you know despite a very
negative situation there is something
positive I love this some of you can
chime in okay we have a very quiet group
today I hope you all are there let me
see if I can pull up my chat box for
some reason it disappeared and I'm not
able to see it but please do share so I
while you're doing that I will share
some of the positive happened for me
right before we went into this global
crisis I was really overwhelmed I had so
much going on so many projects happening
work with my coaching and then also had
a lot of family events going on you know
had a system what a wedding I'm Brad
neat first bryony's coming I had you
know lots of dude was just a lot of a
lot going on and I was and then this
happened and what happened was oh yeah I
got my chatbox back so what happened was
I was yeah I was a woman and this gave
me time you know it has given me time to
work on projects and
worked on it forever you know I love the
fact that all these places are off
including Udacity offering so many free
courses that I love to learn you know my
life if I could spend 50 of my 50
percent of my time learning actually I
think I could be happy be a hundred
percent student for the rest of my life
but you know I need to make a living so
so I love that I can learn and I can
learn in all these different areas that
I love that I have time I love the peace
that this has brought you know as you
take a walk outside and you know it's
not busy it's not as much activity going
on so it's really really really been
such an amazing time in that sense where
you know I always complain that I never
had time in time and now I have more
time the night you know I know what to
do it though I still find ways so so I
love that you know that we have this
time I do see a few responses from you
so I apply from Emily I apply for
different location job because everyone
is with motley I've learned to establish
better boundaries between work life and
personal life which is great for a lot
of people you know I know a lot of
colleagues and and friends who were
never home you know they traveled
24-hour you know lake almost a hundred
percent of the time and now for the
first time they're actually in with
their families for a month and their
children are loving it and their wives
are loving it so that's definitely a
positive and then Abdullah mentioned for
me it's been being able to work from
home again that's great you know so many
companies were so resistant to working
from home and not because it's not
possible but it's kind of like oh I
don't know it really works or not or I
don't know if my employees can be
productive or you know there's lots of
reasons why on these resistance to it
but now this is forced every
kind of like hey you know you need to
make it happen and I feel that once
we're we have this behind us a lot of
companies of initiative models and just
from the cost savings alone you know
being having to to pays or rents and and
maintenance and electricity bill you
have kitchens in your offices you know
if there's a lot of money that goes into
that
I was I was listening to podcast the
other day and and whoever was speaking
was saying that they normally travel or
not to go for interviews and they were
talking to one of the the major
broadcast shows that they normally do
interviews with and they were like their
budget is almost gone because of all the
hotels and the tickets and all that that
they pay for it guess now they're not
having to do that and they're just
having just as the interviews over zoom
over audio so this will definitely
change how business happens in the
future and it will be for a good thing
again Leslie I'm all about being better
to the environment or less of a carbon
footprint and and yeah and giving us
that option of being able to be a little
bit more flexible and having option and
then you also say because I save a lot
of time no not commuting that's great
getting to spend more time with family
and spending less yes that's a huge one
I know I get that for my family a lot to
where their budgets have gone like in
half you know being out and about you
spend money you spend money in fuel you
spend money from store you spend money
eating out so this has definitely been
great on the pockets like I can't even
remember the last time I put fuel in my
car I probably it was probably more than
a month ago and I still have probably
half a tank so definitely a lot of
financial savings so so it's always
great to shift your perspective
especially when you're feeling
overwhelmed this is a great tool you
know and it gets to all of us right we
are like when is this
and you know we go from one month six
months or 12 months everyone has a
different perspective of how this will
play out and we honestly we don't know
there is no one who knows right but but
we'll find out you know but in the
meantime you can choose to focus on the
negative or you can choose to so
definitely I'm happy to hear that a lot
of you had you know can see the positive
in this then the other is what can we
learn and what can we do so in every
negative situation in my life I'd like
to always look to see what can we learn
what can we take away from this position
from this situation you know what is a
positive what can we learn from it just
on all vulnerable ities as humans on our
ability as organizations and how can we
make that better you know just what I've
found it's you know a lot of people okay
you know I had financial trouble you
know so we can learn okay we really need
to be more careful about what we spend
on in the future you know and then what
can we do
what can we do about this there's a lot
of what we cannot do right we cannot
leave our homes we cannot interact with
people that we used to we you know
there's a lot of them you cannot but we
can focus we you know but there is a lot
that we can focus on you know we can
focus on our job search we can focus on
building our networks we can focus on
doing all those projects and we've
always wanted to do that we've never had
the time or opportunity to do so there's
a lot that still can be done and it's
it's pivoting and focusing on that
rather than what's out there okay Joseph
mentioned that I'm actually learning a
lot from courses on platforms like
audacity that's great so many of the
online universities are offering sweet
or very discounted courses and oh my god
I I love it you know you can choose
about any area that you want to expand
upon and then take courses so that's a
great use of your time to serve
okay so let's move to the next so um so
we've kind of done this already where we
shared some positive that's come out of
your life from this experience if
there's any more please feel free to to
keep typing on and and I'll bring that
up as we go along so here this has
called us to adjust our strategy I'm not
sure where some of you and the job
searching I'd love if you shared and
just tell me I you were you in the
process of a very active job search that
it's kind of gonna hold or were you in a
stable job and you're still there but
you kind of want to keep your options
open and see what comes out or maybe
you're just studying and you want to in
graduating soon and looking to see how
this will affect you or maybe position
but we're looking to pivot and and want
to see where this would affect you
because a lot of what we talk about will
be helpful to know what your different
situations are so if you could just type
in the chat box or unmute yourself and
speak up on you know kind of where you
are today in regards to your career or
that's your job search so that way I can
um you know in my recommendations I can
give you specific advice okay um so I'll
give you a minute to do that message
[Music]
okay okay um so again adjusting on our
strategy requires us to be flexible to
get created and again to focus on what
is in our control right so we need to be
flexible you might have been looking for
a very specific kind of position that
has been affected by the current global
situation that were in what can you do
about it can you give it and move into
doing something different you know can
you maybe decide all instead of doing
this I need to provide for my family
during this time so what are other areas
that I can bring an income to support me
until we're past this right so really
getting flexible and looking at yes I
really really wanted to be in this type
of role but because this might not be
happening at this time let me see what
else I could do until email things kind
of come back to some level of normalcy
and I can come back to to my job search
and then obviously getting creative you
know we in our time where these days
always opportunity where I ate some you
know during the Great Depression there
were great companies that will create
you know during some of the market
crashes that we've had there's some
companies that were created you know the
jobs and I think Apple came in that came
out of one of the most difficult times
financially that we were in at the time
and so it's really just figuring out how
you can get creative and get around this
right so what are some skills and
talents that okay maybe it's away from
your general career but that you could
use in order to get you through this
time right so there are some people who
are great bloggers right these a huge
need for communication out there
companies are struggling to get their
message out you know the government's
and and a lot of the nonprofit's who are
helping support during this time need
people who can communicate to get their
messages out so how can you use your
skills talents and abilities in a
creative way to kind of get you through
this time and again focus in
what's new control so reading on what
some of the situations that were in and
so I'm finishing up my last month of a
six month internship and looking for new
opportunities haven't got any interviews
yet that's great I'm glad that you're
able to get that internship you know
before all of this started
and again when it comes to the job
search or interviews a lot of things
that slow down now it doesn't mean that
all the positions are on the way you
know but these are a lot that's
happening with you know hiring managers
just being inundated with you know
having to adjust to the new normal you
know or you know positions going on hold
like I mentioned going
or maybe the HR is very busy with being
you know employees who are affected by
it or they themselves being affected so
then they can't really focus on
onboarding any new people because they
have you know they're dealing with the
situation at hand so this is one of
those rare times in history where
they're kind of all in the same boat you
know the companies you know the people
who are running the companies the job
seekers like we're all literally in the
same boat so just knowing that you know
we don't know what the different
situations are so just having that
patience and continuing to be proactive
with your job search you know one of the
things that I'm a big proponent of is
don't stop don't say okay well I'm gonna
wait until this is over before continue
my job search you know there is
opportunity out there keep going on you
know keep communicating if you're
already doing interviews with companies
and things kind of went from hold
continuing being proactive because at
the end of this you want to be ahead of
the pack you know when they're all of a
sudden oh we're ready to bring people on
board and love about hiring streets you
know you want to be ahead of the pack
and that comes from continuing your job
searching run and communicating so
checking in with you know the hiring
managers you know knowing that hey you
know I understand the situation I know
that now was not the best of times but
you know I still I'm still very much
available and I would like to look
forward as soon as things are moving
again
so someone else said actively applying
and interviewing but companies are
taking a long time to get back we're not
getting back in 10 14 days and I get a
little bit then someone else says I'm
currently working on getting a better
role at the agency I work at I've been
learning a lot these days and it's a
great opportunity to be better at what I
do in a bit more structure that's great
so you're looking for an internal
transfer so you're learning and
preparing for that that's excellent so
Tara mentions I'm searching for work in
a new career that's great
recently started applying opportunities
still have a mine in any interviews yeah
and that's fine so you know so do in
different places of the search and
career but I will definitely make sure
we cover
okay so sectors that are hiring for
those of you who are looking for new
opportunities right so we have
government entities and nonprofits so a
lot of governments are having to really
really gear up and support their people
and as well as assisting especially
communities and people who have been so
looking into them see what kind of
support that's needed and seeing how
your skills talents and abilities can
line up with this obviously healthcare
that's a huge you know saying like boom
especially in certain states that have
been severely affected biotech and
pharmaceuticals again these are squash
to find business rush to find no you
know treat not only treatment but a what
is it called you know to find a way to
deal with this virus right so again
there's a lot that's happening around
research development and so this is
definitely an area that's growing remote
meaning and communication companies who
knew that zoom would be as popular as it
has become today so zoom in the lights
you know so anyone that's supporting
communications and meaning so Microsoft
meetings
you know what's up all of these
companies have definitely seen a huge
uptick because of what's going on and
they probably will continue for a while
you know because again I'm really feel
about how we do business is going to
change we're going to really move to a
much bigger remote model than we worried
before so this will be no an area that
will continue to grow there's no service
firm so again business meeting
businesses are still needing support in
critical areas you know there are still
things that need to happen on a daily
basis businesses that cannot not happen
so that's definitely an area online
learning companies you've all seen and
you know during times like now is always
an increase in people looking to to to
just up skill you know and get stronger
so really looking at some of these
online learning companies and also a lot
of the schools you know I know I'm in
the u.s. I'm actually you know and we as
soon as all the started they shut down
schools until the end of the year you
know and we are in lockdown until
beginning of June so learning is going
to move the software that's needed for
for schools to be able to provide this
kind of online learning so not just all
online schools but companies that
provide support and infrastructure for
schools and about to be able to do
online learning then obviously grocery
stores have been greatly affected
shipping and delivery services Amazon
and children so we heard have been crazy
hiring spree because you know people
ordering more than ever now because they
can't go to store so hurry you could
look into and they're not and you know
for example you might say well there
might not be any jobs in biotech or
pharmaceuticals what can I do in
healthcare there is a lot of back-end
support and it goes into manage
so yeah you might not be about to a
nurse but you positions in healthcare
can support okay and the next step is is
also seeing how you can be of service
you know one of the things that really
everyone is having a challenge with now
is this not being able to do anything
right I know I go crazy when I'm in a
situation and I feel like there's
nothing right I love that can be a game
coach I can continue to be to be working
with what I love the most but a lot of
people don't really have that option or
a lot of people right now their jobs
have gotten old or they have positions
where they can't really work from home
or they are having all this time and
they you know they're tired of taking
courses they don't do that anymore
so what else can you do you know and and
which can also be a benefit to your job
search into your career down the line
again looking to how you can be a part
of the solution you know right so much
of what we do is focus on focusing on
the problem we cannot move there's no
jobs you know everything has slowed down
I'm not hearing math in this but what
can we do we can be a part of the
solution right there's so many things
that are allowing us you know I know a
great amount of you in the tech sector
and I'd love to hear in the group chat
with some of your specialty areas are or
you know what kind of areas were looking
to move into but you know healthful
engineers is a great open source group
looking for solutions of the 19 and they
have they have not going on around that
and I can and I can post a link for that
where you can go check that out and see
how you can support github you can you
can search github or coq au vin 19
open-source projects again looking for
solutions I think the white house posted
something the other day they were
looking for data scientists to help
support a move making
all the data and all the means from this
pandemic and so these lots of
opportunities there that that can be of
use to you and I will share them towards
the end of the call in the group chat so
you can check them out but yeah these
definitely lots of ways that you can
pitch in and be of service and this
would look great on your resume this is
something that you can speak of and once
this is all said and done and this is
also something that can lead into other
positions right you never know some of
these may need it too real positions
down the line so definitely looking into
how you can pitch in and be of service
okay so when it to some of you you know
to kind of just take a little bit of a
pause see how if any of you would be
interested in getting involved how would
you like to get involved where kind of
how do you feel about rain you are in
this process and what you can do and and
yeah just I could take some time to kind
of you know give pause and for you to
share some of your thoughts on where we
are and if you have any questions on
anything that I've said so far feel free
to unmute yourself and speak up or or
take them in the chat box and I respond
and while we wait for you I will find
the links that I can share with you
okay so I'll share with you how I'm
getting involved so that are in the
county that I'm in so I signed up to be
of assistance and there's a lot that can
be done where you don't even need to go
anywhere so there's one where and just
you know been greatly affected by what
is going on and so just you know having
a positive color where you know call in
check in with them on a regular basis
how you doing and coaching them through
the situation so that's one way I've
gotten involved another way is I have
gotten involved with the Virginia
Medical Corps Reserves and again I have
no medical background but they you know
they need a lot of support you know
whether it's logistical support or
administrative support so so I started
signed up recently with them to kind of
give them support in order to help the
people that are really out there might
need
mentioned that skill such great and
honestly right now we need some positive
and these nothing that makes me feel as
good as giving back especially when I'm
in a difficult situation
you know sometimes taking the time to
really you know take the focus off for
yourself and your family and being for
the greater good you know if there's no
better way to really improve and then
Haneen says I'm a web mobile developer
and I'm actually thinking of projects
are showing mind like games with friends
and such hope that can be helpful to
take off some stress that's a great idea
you know right now people looking for
stuff to grasp on you know like I've
seen a lot of these puzzles go around
and all these you know kind of
they're just challenges so that's a
great way to keep people engage and
entertained and you know I see a lot of
people creating Facebook groups where
you know it's all about just engaging a
positive way and everyone kind of
sharing their strengths and their
thoughts and all of that so that's great
so from a marketer's point of view I
think it's important to get back on the
support entertainment or solutions that
make people feel more safe that's what
I'm doing and that's excellent
again balancing out all the negative
news like oh you know I'm really really
big on that and I'm loving all the
positive messaging that's out there like
I'm making my intention you know I
honestly I can I cannot have you I
realized after the first two weeks when
I was glued to the news and I was really
calling me it really affected my state
of being and when I really disconnected
all of that and and really focused on
the type of media that I was taking in
and focus on the positive
I definitely changed my view of how I
you know of how I'm going about the
situation which again if you're going in
with a positive attitude that will
affect your job search now will affect
how you engage with people and everyone
is needing the that positivity and also
that's great and I believe being
empathic is key and we're all going we
are all going through the same exactly
my point
as in we're all in this globally you
know there's not one country that has
that I know of that has not been
affected by this you know we are we are
literally in this together and so just
realizing that no matter who you're
coming across they're kind of in the
same boat so being empathic being kind
being you know supportive in any way
that you can and then Joseph mentions
I'm recently engineering graduate I can
help in any project that's data related
the skills I'm learning from the data
analyst that's great Joseph again these
that Paul from the White House and they
looking for data analyst and being
scientist so again I'll post a link to
that and so feel free to look at that
you know check github for coab in 19
sources check the engineering the group
that I mentioned earlier but you can
look into so yeah great ways to get
involved so glad to hear so many of you
are open to that so that was actually
looking to share the share the resources
okay so let's move on to the next so
bringing you back together you know
again I keep coming back to this because
it's so important these opportunity in
every situation as job as a job market
seems there are people that hiring I
know people that have received job
offers this week you know so just
because it slowed down just because
you're not hearing back does not mean
you need to stop continue what you're
doing continue remaining positive
sometimes you may need to take a break
to kind of just get yourself together
and and you know just up again you know
whatever it takes you know do something
that you love do something that kind of
particular take your mind off things and
then come back to to what your goal is
and in fact job search continues in that
way but you know the key is just
realizing that this opportunity in every
situation there will be an end to this
this will not be forever right so you
want to make sure that you ahead of the
pack when this happens so continue doing
what you're doing
continue building the networks
connecting with people online finding
people that you admire and seeing you
can we talk to them and speak to them
and connect with them in meaningful ways
you know continuing your job search so
then follow us to to hiring managers you
know whatever stage that and whatever
stage you are in the job search and then
taking into consideration you know
mental physical and emotional health
again this is huge you know if you're
not in the right state of mind a state
of being then forget a job search forget
a career forget you you know I know
people who haven't been able to work you
know because they're so stressed out
about
going on and how this will affect their
families or how this will affect their
lives or you know and they just can't
focus on on their work at this time so
definitely making sure you take into
consideration your mental physical
emotional health and doing what you can
so getting out there being active
exercising you know getting fresh air
yes we're you know where most I know in
some states you not only know like for
example in California I know in some
places you can still go out for walks
when you're as long as your social
distancing you know so make sure you're
getting in society they're not able to
you know look up YouTube videos where
you can exercise that can help you get
rid of some of that stress you know look
at doing whatever appeals to you to give
you mental peace of mind whether you
know some people it could be yoga
meditation some people could be art you
know some people to be playing with
their children and watching funny videos
but whatever it takes make sure that in
every single and also your emotional you
know again when unprecedented
unprecedented times that are really
really really stepping up a lot of our
concerns you know and a lot of fears you
know our subconscious fears are coming
up to serve this you know we're going to
be okay I'm gonna be golden right and so
really being finding a way to express
those emotions don't suppress them and
go and open the fridge every time you're
feeling you know an uncomfortable
feeling you know if you have some tell
them how you're feeling allow yourself
to be vulnerable with them and they will
likely be in the same situation you know
but just know that again it's nice
sharing and really looking at where you
are is what's going to help you get
through this at the end and then
obviously crowding out the negativity
with positive steps towards miracles
again this
so much out there you know try and cut
down the new sources as much as you can
and it should be order as needed basis
it shouldn't be 24 hours a day you know
sometimes you know it's almost addictive
right you just want to hear more and
more and there's nothing that's changing
you know we've pretty much of the apex
of what they'll already know what we
need to do you know we need to stay away
from people we need to you know keep
washing our hands we need to really
release them the spread of do that the
fact that we can get out of it so really
there's no need for you to engage in the
negativity day in and day out so if you
have people or you have new sources or
you have you know if it's social media
that's getting you on the negative side
of things you know check in with
yourself and say hey whenever I do this
I feel this afterwards you know and stop
doing the things that make you feel
really low and negative and do more of
the things that help you feel more
positive right so what can you do
towards your career goals
you know visioning coming back to your
goals what was the most important to you
why do you want to you know get into
what it is that you're doing you know I
know I did a webinar a few weeks ago or
a month ago on goal-setting and vision
you know that's a great time to come
back to that you know going back to that
space of imagination and what what what
you know what drives you what are you
passionate about you know and continuing
to focus on that because that will still
become a reality
if that's still the most important thing
to you and you don't allow this thing to
kind of take over and then the last
thing is obviously finding a way to be
of service you know again there's no the
one thing about this situation it's
connecting us as a humanity in a way
that nothing has in a long time you know
and really coming to the end of this and
knowing that you contributed in a
positive way where there's to your work
whether it's even just you know and you
don't have to go there and do anything
crazy you don't have to leave your house
you know it could be just motivating
your co-workers you know suggesting a
zoom happy hour or just reaching out to
someone who you feel has them you know
super-quiet or just seeming disengaged
you know but you can reach out in bigger
small ways but knowing that everything
will have an effect on the on the whole
you know and the more small smaller acts
of service that we can do individually
each of us step in and do what we can
and do something positive there will be
a huge impact globally so that's pretty
much what I have I did share about some
of the resource that I've talked about
so the health food engineering group and
I included a link to that in the chat I
included github to search for koban 19
resources I included the link for the
white house call to arms for data
scientists as well as internships so
right now some of you are looking to
pivot careers of moving to a whole new
career so I know a lot of you know we
were coming into the summer season and
so a lot of our full-time students were
looking to do internships of this
inexperience and now that's probably
gone away with the current situation
that we're in so looking into virtual
internships or remote internships so
I've included a couple of things for
that experience even in the situation
that we're in I think those one of you
that mentioned that they're competing us
it's my internship now and we're
starting to you know go into the job
search so that's something to definitely
look into so yes so those are a few
resources on they can look into how to
get back for those of you who are job
searching they're things to think about
like for example now there's no one
who's doing in-person interviews so
learning how to do video interviews and
showing up in the right way you know
what is video interview etiquette you
know making sure that you kind of
practice before you you know kind of
look at yourself you know it's very very
different speaking to a screen versus
speaking to someone you know especially
if they're also not on video on the
other side so learning kind of this way
of being you know looking up way
in short and be and you know really show
up in the best way but over video online
versus in person I'm so looking up how
to do that and and and again networking
looking how to build your network online
you know now is a great time when a lot
of people who are really really busy
with it who might have never had a
chance to reply to your LinkedIn message
or any of that now might have time to
connect so looking to you know
continuing reaching out to people who
seem important to you and just learning
as much as you can scheduling a
five-minute call asking them questions
over email whatever it may take but
continue to make a priority to build
that network on so there are any final
questions or concerns that you have that
I can answer for you any resources that
I can give you now would be the time to
ask I'll give you just a few moments
again you're welcome to to unmute
yourself or you can send a question over
the chat box it seems a lot of this
group ism is prefers to chat which is
great so just please share any last
questions that you had if you have any
sense of challenges that you're having
basic me to address definitely let me
know as well
okay any questions okay so while I wait
for questions I'll go into the next
slide so Udacity is here to support you
right we have so many resources that are
available to you we have a ton of
resources online and I'll not click I'll
actually share a link with all of you on
just the various career resources that
we but yeah we have resume you know now
again we have time right so now it's a
great time to really review your
application material make sure that it's
perfect you know we have a resume review
process we have a LinkedIn review
process but you can submit you'll get ha
any cover letters use this time to make
sure your application materials a tip to
the top you know make sure you linked in
is tip-top we have so many resources on
our Career Center we obviously have you
can join us for one-to-one coaching
sessions challenges that you have e
we're actually having weekly career
coaching events on Tuesdays at 9 a.m.
PST they're you know kind of very casual
but again are we created them to address
the situation they were in and any
specific questions they might have
within the job search within career
during specifically during coded 19 so
this is every week we normally have
three or four career coaches on their
answering your questions sharing best
practices a lot of times I mean we're
all learning from each other you know no
one knows the best way to navigate this
so so this is a great time for you to
connect with other Udacity students
without the Udacity alumni as well as
career coaches again this is a weekly
basis on Tuesdays at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time or noon 12:00 noon Eastern Time we
have the student hub where you can ask
questions and they can get answered
either by the students or
or career coaches and normally we'll get
back to you pretty quickly we have
career coaching hours within the student
hub where a career coach is available in
our life and can answer your questions
so we have lots of resources I did share
a link for career we sort of our career
resources Center you can click on that
and see what's available to you from
your classroom you can click on career
and see also what's available to use and
definitely take advantage of all the
Udacity career resources and really get
you know now that we have the time you
know get your resume all of that in
tip-top shape get us to review if
there's a specific area in your career
that you really want to do a deep dive
if you want to prepare for technical
interviews or you know or looking for
specific advice in an area that you're
really struggling and schedule a one on
one call one of us for you magda
provided a great link for virtual
internships on the inside sharpen comm
so please these lots of great resources
and just to let you know at the end of
the call you can save the chat like you
see three buttons and you just click on
that it will have the option to save the
chat so you can save as we go along or
different things that we're sharing or
you could save at the end but that's a
great way to to kind of keep up with all
the resources that being shared so thank
you monkey for sharing that on the on
the virtual internships and so we have a
question so have been searching for a
job for the last two and a half months
in such case shall I now who would
intern and paid wait long can you put up
on it I would say getting any kind of
experience is better than not so rather
than just sitting try and see whatever
comes first right so if there's any
unpaid internships available go for it
if you if there any open source projects
you can get up you can get involved in
because again that's experience the keys
20 new gaming us
even during this time so yes I would say
go for whatever it is that can get you
working and productive and getting
experience until you can get a position
so animol I'll definitely say you know
take whatever you can obviously your
your your priority will be to get
something that's paid and either the
position that you really want but this
is where this time cause you to be
flexible okay and then Miguel mentioned
I need help with Korea transition tips
have been driving for four years and I'm
trying to get it under this jump I
cannot but I do have the gap and don't
know how the experience will help me get
out of this job so again Miguel it's not
focusing on what you've done but what
you you know what you can do right so
right now you can get involved these so
many open-source projects around data
engineering and data analysis see how
you can get involved and get experience
you know look at how you can get
internships you know initially while
you're doing a current job driving you
can still be doing internships you know
I can we have the virtual internships we
have open source projects you can get a
bill they can get experience with and
put that on your resume once you have a
little bit of experience then it becomes
easier to get a job the other thing is
offering yourself to companies that are
struggling right now so for example I
mentioned that I am volunteering with
the Virginia Medical Reserve or they
might need data analyst you know and and
so finding out how some of these public
service organizations and volunteer
organizations need support because they
do need it at this time from analytics
perspective and seeing how you can get
support again that's something they can
actually resume and compete in to a job
in the future
so in in Miguel you know feel free to
schedule a call with the one-on-one
coach and that way and that again comes
with your Udacity no no degree where you
can get nice I'm not and then I mean
says I have the option to extend my
internship or edit at six times I can't
decide whether to do that or edit at six
month and look for jobs if you can do a
little bit of both I need that
maybe let them know you're my basis and
just be honest be able to transition
into a full-time position but you have
to support them until you do that and so
that way you still continue into an
experience but maybe you can even reduce
your hours you know what I've put more
hours into your job search so maybe say
instead of 40 hours a week of 30 hours a
week and then you know continue
supporting you until you know I can I
can get a job so if you can do both
that's great you know because again you
want to continue gaining as much
experience as you can because we don't
know how how long were in this world we
could be in this for three weeks and
life goes back to normal
oh it could be in this for six months so
it's again being flexible and being
prepared for both the best-case scenario
and the worst-case scenario so it looks
like we've come to the end of our time
here it was such a pleasure speaking
with you all I do hope that you know
this was helpful for you please use the
resources that you know I gave you go to
udacity.com slash events to see links to
any future career related events that
we're having again I sent the link on
the career on all the various career
sources that are available through you
to you from Udacity a post again so
please use that but really just remain
positive see how you could be of service
do not you know continue your job search
continue focusing on what it is that you
want and and we'll all come out of it so
thank you all thank you all for being
selective and and I wish you all a great
weekend ahead those of you who celebrate
Easter happy Easter thank you everyone
and don't and please remember to save
the chat the three little dots and then
press save chat and that will save the
chat for you all right thank you thank
you